[Music]
in blind burglar news oh my god what the
hell submitted by corey hassle or hassel
not quite sure I'm gonna give it a
little flair huh cell I think the
herself on a hot day so a blind burglar
was jailed for his hundred and ninety
second offence after leading police on a
chase into a river of course into a
river he's blind I don't think he was
robbing anybody I genuinely believe he
thought it was own house maybe we're
assuming he was blind this whole time
maybe he was blinded by mace Oh or
something but I'm pretty sure he was a
blind burglar oh the blind burglar he's
been burglarizing how does he know what
he's stealing yeah this man his name is
Paul he's 55 years old he has a degree
of partial vision so he can kind of see
but he's legally blind oh so he's a
blurry burglar yeah so he because he has
partial vision and he's able to walk
could only see like a Rolex and see like
a Mercedes but everything else he counts
one of these things no like being yeah
his bad eyesight has never or hasn't
stopped him from pursuing his dreams
a hundred and ninety-one previous
criminal offenses we said he got caught
every time seem like a guy got caught if
it's on his record he's talented
wait what is it a hundred and what
ninety ninety two times he got caught no
no he didn't get caught that Mini that's
points on his well what is it was what
was the terminology used it's a hundred
and ninety two offensive so what happens
is you could get caught once but they
could put you on for like 20 things
oh so even if you get guilty for that or
whatever you're like you know that's why
they say three counts of murder 50
counts of burglary or whatever I'm gonna
measure that one two three
nice game it depends on the law that
they broke okay but if you if you only
have two hands so you can only go to ten
what about your [ __ ] toes huh oh then
110 to
you know that food did another one he's
so old now
oh really yeah guys [ __ ] hilarious
all the whole crews so old but still
funny he's trying to speak English you
know the 10-10-10 guy with the [ __ ]
duck on it we got to show you that
you're gonna laugh till you cry so their
editors put them up look at it right
okay now I might as well just play it
what is it go just put I don't know ten
ten guy put ten ten ten ten
all right there is already there you're
gonna cry to death again eighteen
nineteen
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's funny and then they get spanked
if you laugh with a big stick with a sec
he's genuinely the same crew though yeah
he's genuinely trying that's why it's so
hard not to laugh dude I remember when I
first saw that I was in tears yeah then
watch it again in a [ __ ] me means
yeah bull counted to a hundred like that
so he goes on advice of blind guy the
police were alerted to a break-in at
this abandoned area and they found this
dude wasn't Paul they found Paul there
holding like [ __ ] son like stolen pipes
because apparently he was just stealing
scrap metal and so they they caught him
red red-handed
and what no nothing I'm just in my own
head go ahead when they approached him
he ended up trying to run away and then
he went into a river yeah
he ended up going into a river trying to
swim away but they still called I don't
think you saw I think he just fell into
a river what does he look like mr. Magoo
that's so [ __ ] funny though man I
honestly think he should be a
motivational speaker though cuz nothing
stopped him from Robin :
I know that's perseverance people all my
friends told me I couldn't rob any homes
and I said look you I'm gonna do it
anyways but I could always steal stuff
that was shot because I was blind so I'm
with all my friends told me oh my
friends told me that I just pictured a
guy that looks like Ray Charles with the
walking sticks the homeboys like this
and then he's he's like he's smarter
than everybody else like he just goes up
[ __ ] walks into the house steals the
maracas leaves and then he's like the
blind bandit I wanted to create a movie
called the blind p.i and how that how
that movie starts off is literally this
dude just screaming at somebody
interrogation room and then when you
zoom out there's nobody in there because
he's blind you get a chair for a song
like five minutes he gets mad and nobody
tells him and also this [ __ ] just keeps
on getting situations because he's blind
but everybody member yeah but that I
people tell me that be very insensitive
but I was gonna do it anyways just to
the idea cost too much money oh so it's
not the insensitivity that stops me it's
the money part I I see it a different
way I'm very proud of this guy because
he has 192 offenses
no Julia that's [ __ ] up I'm it's cuz
he's blind and he can do things that
other people can he's overcoming a lot
of obstacles in life why earlier you
implied that you were impressed about
his numbers yeah I didn't say I was
impressed it sounded like it I'm pretty
impressed I'm inspired by him think he's
impressed
why can't you not by the numbers I'm
impressed by your t-shirt creeping is my
specialty because if a guy wore that
shirt it would be way different
oh yeah he'd probably get arrested yep
no guy could wear that shirt and it
would be really cute only women and
children women and children I creeped on
tip once and probably never again
because I really could girl if I was 60
years old and wore that shirt what do
you mean you creeped on her so it was I
remember I was at your old house and I
think we're all just chilling there I
was during the Costco shoot I remember
that clearly you know so I think TIFF
was just like chilling on the couch and
then Alice coming I think I was like
creeping up on her through the hallways
so all I did was like from the wall it's
like this is the wall right so I'm like
this more like yeah I don't think you
were smiling though cuz that's the part
that creeped me out you were just
staring at me and I'm like did you just
go like the ring yeah it was creepy
asian girl can do asian girls game like
you look like a spirit that's very true
and I'm glad you've never done that this
oh yeah cuz I think from that like k
never doing that ever again in this
group I remember asking you something
like like
or something you're like I'm just trying
to make you feel uncomfortable and I'm
like yeah I think I even mentioned exams
I think you were kind of or one of you
two was kind of new so you guys were
nest high and then you were like Julie
doesn't like me uncomfortable yeah it
was she had just came in sorry
okay guys like business this is an
icebreaker for me and I I figure it out
it doesn't work for everyone
it works for most people this is how how
[ __ ] up I am with social media as soon
as I saw that Ghost I was like always
what's up with snapchat on the shirt
yeah this match at logo isn't it like
maybe creeping I think I think it is a
snapchat mobile oh is it
I think so creeping on snapchat is my
specialty it's just just as creeping is
my specialty
I thought creeping on it is but without
the eye the other eye has no eyes
that's the Chinese version then they
added eyes for copyright [ __ ] but it's
the exact same one even with the arms
even with the arms with all girls could
get away with so much more things than
guys
oh yeah cuz we were just not trying to
jack off and [ __ ] everything what guys
you trying to jack off all the [ __ ]
time uh yeah a job
[Music]
I try to be on your side but I am NOT a
liar
he told us he [ __ ] the couch that's
right you did [ __ ] a couch hey hey hey
that was hey that was a long time ago
movies called American Pie cuz [ __ ]
wanted [ __ ] [ __ ] a pie dude I hit it
like falling asleep in class and they're
waking up with morning wood you don't
have a dick stop talking about it
Paul the no reason boners yeah dude [ __ ]
was so [ __ ] annoying cuz I would wake
up and the bell would ring right now
everybody has to go to class I'm sitting
there and I'm asking the teacher
questions about stuff I don't really
give a [ __ ] about because I need time
for the butter to die sometimes I just
put the backpack in front of me and walk
out what about your binder it's driver
like I did that than that before mm-hmm
I heard you guys put it on the white the
waistline or something I said you have
to first sometimes yeah it's like a
necktie but from the bottom first you
put your hat at your pocket adjust your
dick because if it's if your pabts is if
this is your pants and then your wieners
like here and it's fighting to go up
like this it's the jeans are getting
stuck and it's like a diving board yeah
I just want it to just die cuz I didn't
want it flipped up in my waistband
because that might even feel good why
don't you get a piece of duct tape and
then tape it to where it's like tucked
in by your butt cheek and that looks
like you have a vagina
why don't you do that if you have a
boner you Kat it's freaking stiff as
[ __ ] yep but I did see this one point
where a guy was bent over like a doggy
style and he was hard and a girl pulled
his wiener back like he had a tail and
sucked it well he's a really long good
thing do something to do that I'll do it
round like that
how do I know that what do you mean I
can't do that I mean I can that's not
what I asked
this is how do you know that and ask if
you can do there's like that no there's
pornos were like the girls like this
she's on the back on the floor like this
right and then that guy's like on the
couch and then his dick is like facing
downwards
oh yeah push my dick I've never done
dick yoga so you can't push it down over
like this I straight but they're dicks
or quite massive
we don't know what what it's like to
have like a [ __ ] tennis dong yeah
true cuz I'm a grower not a shower
yeah cuz this right here what are you
gonna do with like the best idea it
might be different story because mine
definitely in this large this you see
you talk about it goes right now could
you imagine it enters your vagina and
literally hits your friend here yeah you
guys are missing the point we're talking
about a blind burglar that was out on
the loose and now you were talking about
sex how dare you I'm ashamed of all you
guys I wasn't the one who painted that
up but now that we brought this up it
just reminded me David brought it up if
we really think about it this a porno
blooper that I saw those it was a
blooper corner you're a pervert David
chubby more outtakes a port yeah oh is
it wouldn't a guy farts in her face and
even she's eating his ass and he farted
she got mad at him was this one thing
where they had a stop do to take of the
girl couldn't stop laughing because the
guy's dick was so huge you could see his
dick imprint in her stomach towards here
so you see it just pushed her uterus or
whatever do you see it like she couldn't
stop laughing cuz it looked like an
alien she wasn't her it's the old port I
think I saw that like probably like
seven or eight years she had a fro like
it was disco times no she was like she
what you think something similar 17
years ago it wasn't let alone hey guys
if you guys didn't know we have a social
media account on Instagram call it the
JK film so you guys should better follow
it because we post up clips pictures we
got some insta stories going on so go
ahead and fall it right now in the next
video click up here
[Music]